the general data protection regulation
or gdpr as you've likely heard it called
it goes into effect on May 25th and it
could affect you no matter where you are
or where you live how let's answer some
questions so what is gdpr it tightens
Europe's already strict laws about what
companies can do with people's data it
gives you more control over how your
data is collected and used and forces
companies to justify everything that
they do with it while gdpr is European
Union legislation it has a huge effect
on businesses outside the EU including
the US why was gdpr introduced because
the old laws were written before
smartphones started collecting massive
amounts of sensitive information for
companies like Google and Facebook gdpr
gives organizations guidelines on what
they can and can't do with personal data
it also makes them give users more
clarity over the kind of data being used
and how companies will use it what is
considered personal data under GDP are
any data that can identify you
that's your name phone number or user
name but the law also includes things
like your IP address or location data
even tighter rules apply for sensitive
information such as sexual orientation
health data and political opinions how
will it affect you one way is that you
will often have to opt in to letting a
company use your data this means fewer
pre ticked boxes and firms are compelled
to use clear and simple language
do people have the right to be forgotten
yes people can request to have their
data deleted personal data also needs to
be transferable via a common file type
however the right to be forgotten is not
absolute and certain conditions apply
why is gdpr a concern for non EU
countries because many businesses
collect or use EU residents data they
also use companies based in the EU for
services and processing data what
happens if a firm doesn't comply with
GDP are the penalty could be up to 20
million euros or 4% of annual turnover
whichever is larger
[Music]